you're private you want a picture of
your friends
whoa
back off my broccolini get your life
together
touch me bro i'm not touching you dude
[Music]
a special episode chrissy d the culture
corner
look at this yeah you know cat has an
only fans account now oh
beautiful that's what you're going to
make money yeah really she's making
money i get it
sir real money money
yeah of course that's the richest one in
the room now i believe it yeah
i believe it she should have gone
assistant like after you go through her
assistant out of yeah
i believe it yeah all right sign up
would you let your girl do a only fancy
no oh [__] she [__] hates him dude
i there's i would bet i'd be willing to
bet a thousand dollars that
she leaves with the kids before may 24th
is it not going well we shooting a tv
show for the viewers that don't know
you're shooting a tv show for how long
um i'm here for
um i'm here for four months don't be a
[__] just move out here dude all my
friends laughter got canceled
i know i should just move out here but
the problem is is i love i'm not gonna
be one of those guys
because i don't i'd like l.a yeah but
it's just place on earth our governor
sucks
but dude i gotta be honest with you if
i'm gonna be honest please i mean listen
from new york the pandy wendy is i get
it it's scary i get it i'm not saying
cove it's not real
but i mean dude the hysteria about it in
this town is a little
it's a little absurd is it not where
it's like dude [__]
relax i mean they they they came and
kova tested me this morning for this
[__] dumb true tv
thing and then they cover tested my
whole family i'm like what she's
five yeah she's not going anywhere stop
then i was jogging yesterday with no
mask on and
in the [__] park in balboa park so
just just me somebody's like can you put
a mask on sir
i was like dude you're gay
[Laughter]
it's weird because like we uh we're on
tour i was in cleveland i was tampa
and you go on the news there and there's
like there's like hope right there's
like vaccinations we're opening up
football's opening up basketball here
you turn on the news like we're three
masks like what the [__] it's so stupid
it's so different here like you have to
wear a butt plug it's just
it kind of feels like like i want to
just kind of walk up to people like dude
trump lost
he lost you could take the mask off now
you can calm down because at first it
was like
i'm wearing a mask to prove that i do
not spur donald trump
and i'm just like okay fine he's lost
enough yeah you're so crazy it's like
because when did then then
so now we get the vaccine now there's a
new strain from [__] narnia whatever
so say we get one doctor algae fouch he
says we're past that
when does it end then do you just wear
the mask for the rest of your life how
fearful
do you want to be i hear some people
going i'm just going to wear a mask for
the rest of my i just changed my life
oh [__] weird oh we can't do it yeah
dude
wait do in new york do they have to wear
them outside mask
listen the kind of thing in new york is
most people wear it
outside though we wear especially if
you're in a crowd but like outside if
you're walking around with no mask on
it's just like fine
inside mask gyms man like even when i
got here it's like the gyms and
restaurants have been open
in new york for three months you gotta
come to my gym dog yeah
dumbbells come to zoo culture i know
you're supposed to work you risked this
morning yeah because i had to get
different
sun because i got because i got
because i had to get to stupid because i
had to get the stupid cover test this
morning but i'm gonna try to come
here tomorrow yeah we're there tomorrow
yeah wait a minute
you guys have the sleds you push the
slides oh yeah i like to do this
circuit sleddies you come in shorts get
the cheeks out i'll get those cheeks out
i'm christian
the square i wanna i want to eat that
cake but i'm on my fitness pal i don't
have the calories
i know i don't either but i'll try it no
but you look slim and hot i'm trying dog
i'm down some i've been on a diet got a
little too thick now that cake's for
uh theo vaughn and my birthday which is
today happy birthday thanks buddy and
theo's is tomorrow yeah until still
gonna be here that's why we sent out
that chrissy d
imagine the kind of [__] you have to
be to not even show up for your own
birthday party
way to go theo way to go could you
imagine
dude they had a birthday party for you
and you're in [__]
asheville sticking chicken wings up your
ass no nothing was better two
was it two yeah two years ago you know
uh he was like hey let's get each other
gifts i'm like all right
i give him you know i'm a sneaker i give
them some jordan one pines these green
and black jewels
he gave me a theo von merch t-shirt
that's our relationship he wrote you he
got you a little card too he wrote that
that's our relationship in a nutshell
dude theo vaughn
first of all i've you know how long have
you known theo
six years six years see i've known theo
i've know why i probably know theo about
six
seven years but i knew theo when you
know theo had
nothing when i met him he had nothing
yeah oh when you met him
nothing again he was making money finger
and finger in old ladies yeah i i have a
dm where
uh the first time we met came on firing
the kid at fox yeah like six seven years
ago
and he goes hey dude my album just
dropped my comedy album can you blast it
out for me really help tweet this out
and he's doing like you know making two
thousand dollars a week and now he's one
of the greatest comics
[__] walking yeah now he won't show
up to his own damn show
theo i'll [__] eat your cake dude i
want to eat that so bad
i swear to god dude i'll eat it if you
come chrissy is going to eat your ass
how about 100
theo he's about he's cheeked up now he
does he's getting his fatty back because
he used to have a high he used to have
like a high white ass
for a while but he lost it now no he's
still got his name he still has his ass
he's doing a lot like his trainer has
him do a lot of squats a lot of yeah
that thing's getting plump dude yeah man
theo i dude i wanna
next time i see him i may shave his head
i may just do that i may just shave the
mullet off yeah he's gonna lose his
power then could you imagine if i just
held him down and we shaved his head
as a prank you'd look like gi jane it'd
be a bad idea
i know because right now i used to say
he looks like eileen wernos i don't know
if you know the serial ki yeah you know
that
yeah oh for a monster yeah but the
actual like woman who's
the real one like the real eileen his
hair was kind of it looks a little bit
like that
now oh yeah yeah
yeah i said it on op and anthony once
but r.i.p to that show and me and theo
used to do that show together
and uh and yeah we pulled this picture
up and it was crazy
wait who's that lady she's she's the
first female serial killer
charlie ever got executed charlie
charlie's uh theron did the
movie monster uh-huh and it was
charlie's theron played her yeah
and she put on like 40 pounds no she put
on 40 pounds she was identical to her
she transformed into it oh okay because
i was like what
she does not look like charlie stuff do
you know charlize theron
like just got discovered like in like a
store
like some director was just walking by
and she was like the checkout girl and
he was like you're so beautiful
really that's how she got discovered you
know guy richie found jason stay them
same way he was like hustling like
watches in london yeah and he was like
holy [__] dude you look cool you look
cool
i was trying to get to that and then
everything is starting to be like like
you know the more and more i go through
this career i'm like even with acting
it's like i'll do it but it's like you
i love how actors just take an actress
just take themselves
so seriously it's like you're making
believe you're somebody else that [__]
my five-year-old daughter does it's like
shut up i don't care what you have to
say about the whale calm down
just shut up dude just get the award
you're so
[__] lucky yeah so but also remember
like when the pandemic came out or when
all the blm movement was going on
and they would create those videos
it was like white people being like it's
not okay
privileged oh my god not okay
yeah i'm like what the [__] you know
what guy from breaking bad
listen i said can we get a guy who
represents you
i saw you guys in one of those videos i
punched you in the face
listen as a white guy when i see when i
see why people apologizing for the
privilege i have to be
i would imagine as a black guy they must
hate that
oh it's annoying because to me if i
would you know if i saw if i saw a black
guy
apologizing for whatever a black
privilege i'd be like i don't trust you
at all dude like
like i wouldn't trust a white person
apologizing for their privilege i'm like
what are you actually hiding
yeah right there what are you actually
what are you hiding
because i wasn't looking at you but now
that you want to say how great you are
now it's weird
now i know you understand what you've
done that's incredibly racist
i mean bill burke what happened of all
time this is the best what do you
what do you say i didn't see bill bird
you didn't see that yeah they were
trying to cancel them for this which is
[__] but it's
like canceling bill bird you can't he
never acknowledges it was that the only
one who wanted to kill himself during
that piano solo
[Laughter]
this is the part that pissed in for me i
am losing so much money right now
all right shout out to all the rock
stars that i wanted to meet tonight who
are watching at home instead i'm talking
to you don dawkin
all right what i'm old that was my first
concert
all right here are the next categories
all right hey how many uh feminists are
like going nuts
why is this this white male doing all
this latino
that was the part that just pissed jen's
ears off they were
yeah they're all like you're canceled
you're canceled but he never
acknowledges it he just keeps moving on
and yeah
what are you go you can't cancel no one
can you can't end someone for that
dude people need to go you might get
kicked off star wars
maybe you know give me a bunch of
[__] yeah
okay so who cares though no that
wouldn't affect billy it won't affect
him one of the greatest
[__] comics alive this was the best
in response to it someone said uh
gen z calling billboard racist and they
showed a picture with him
and nia his african-american wife his
black wife oh my god look at this
[__]
[__] wait what possibilities well i'm
not suggesting bill burr
is racist the white man having a
non-white wife can sometimes be a sign
so you shouldn't assume someone's at
racist just because they own a mine
own a minority sex servant what they may
very well have one because they're
racist oh no and
that guy should get punched in the face
and and bill burr's wife responded with
this
yes i love people just lighting these
people up oh god
because it's over it's all very hard
everyone's sick of your [__]
you gotta move on yeah cause now it's
getting to the point where we're like
we have to go back to work the boredom
is over a lot of people realize that i
mean that account is real but most of
these accounts are not real they're
russian bots
it's like we're starting to understand
like america we're starting to win the
war because i believe we're in
world war three right now on twitter
correct with russia because we're never
going to invade russia and they're not
going to invade us
but i think we are working anymore
because it's like
so many people it's like they'll just
create an account and then it'll be the
exact opposite of what you think
will just some somebody in russia will
make an account and you'll just fight
with that account
but now i start to feel like with all
these documentaries coming out and just
seeing it you're like oh it's not real
so now when somebody tweet
if you just look at any type of
controversial tweet something that has
like thousands of comments
you'll see some of the same exact
comments i mean the same words in the
same place
with seven different accounts with seven
different avatars and yes see that's
what i'm saying a lot of times
we're fighting with people they're not
real and they never were real it's
but usually even the ones that comment
even if they are real you realize they
have like 17
followers and they're like oh zero
people are in their basement yeah
dude no no that's not for me those
[__] deep down this right now [__]
take it to the head i like a little
circumcised bottle of water
whoa okay what is up king the thing
listeners listen man
is there something interfering with your
happiness or is preventing you from
achieving your real goals what is it man
quit talking to your friends your
knucklehead friends
and get with a real licensed
professional therapist with
better help you can start communicating
under 48 hours not a crisis line
it's not self-help it's professional
counseling done securely online all
right
the service available worldwide mr
worldwide
uh you get timely and thoughtful
responses plus you can schedule weekly
video or
phone sessions all right we got you
covered man it's more affordable than
traditional on
offline counseling and financial aid is
also available better help once you
start living a happier life
today visit betterhelp.com
cats that's better help dot com slash
cats and join the over one million
people who have taking charge
of their mental health with the help of
an experienced professional
in fact so many people have been using
better help they are recruiting
additional counselors in all 50 states
this podcast is sponsored by betterhelp
and kingston listeners get 10 off their
first months
at betterhelp.com k-a-t-s
hello fresh hello fresh thank god
they cut out the stress of meal planning
and grocery store trips
so you can enjoy cooking and get dinner
on the table about 30 minutes or less
it's one less thing you have to worry
about you got kids you got work you're
busy
let hellofresh help you out man with 25
plus recipes to choose from each
freaking week
they're gonna get you covered man over
four out of five hello fresh customers
say hello fresh helps them
lead a healthier lifestyle with
delicious low calorie
carb smart and vegetarian options
available each
freaking week man all right we got you
covered
uh they sent me my meals i love them
it's easy again it's one less thing i
have to worry about
so go to hellofresh.com
king and use the code 12 king for 12
free meals
including free shipping it's america's
number one meal kit
hello fresh who's this is it transgender
because i got the biggest transgender
fan base
yeah this is our first king at her
stinging speaking of people in their
basement
it's up to you in shop i have a king it
or sing it would you get a painting of a
serial killer in your house
this is some [__] yeah i struggle with
this
portrait of ken bundy
and i'm thinking of the night stalking
there oh i hear you dude i thought about
that
gang gang buzz bumps night stalker
listen if you want to talk about most
beautiful
serial killers richard ramirez is numero
um dude nobody had those teeth those
pouty he got a fixed dog he got veneers
yeah no even when he got veneers and he
smiled he's talking about a rock star
line
l.a you know in encino for a couple of
months and i'm i'm i'm laying in bed
last night like thinking like
i'm s it sucks he's dead i would love to
come in and get raped by him
he's a good looking guy
he had a high chance of getting raped by
that man i know dude he would come dude
he was such a psychopath though because
he would like
kill men women then like molest children
let them go yeah he would ain't really
raped men and women yeah he didn't
[__] dudes yes you don't care because he
said he was just possessed by satan
he was just fully he thought satan was
telling him what to do and by him being
like making the worst crime scene
he was pleasing satan yeah but and
what's weird like you read about the
book he's such a shame like he
grew up his you know hard-working
mexican family he's one of five he was
hard on him right his dad was hard and
beat the family but he like he came from
the office he's dad's piece of [__] but
he had a loving mom
super loving sister like he was the
little one of the family they loved him
he got good grades
and then he would get uh seizures and
just like pass out
and they thought it was uh when he was
like in fourth grade he was on a swing
set and
was knocked unconscious for like an hour
and so they think it [__] up something
yeah and then his uh his uncle went to
vietnam
and was super [__] and came back and
like took him under his wing
but he came from a good family like his
family saw it as [__]
but then that uncle would like basically
was like that was his protege and uncle
came back from vietnam super [__] up
and uh he apparently killed like 30
people over there but he had a bunch of
pictures
of him like with a girl in vietnam a
prisoner and he'd like show a picture
under her head like her second as dick
the next picture would be her with her
head cut off oh i got some ideas for
your only fans
ramirez photoshoot
right there he goes wait that's not a
bad pitch
i gotta do the reverse though then get a
white guy yeah i have to get a little
use mexican but yeah because
i would just pretend that like i was the
viet cong who would that be
the reverse yeah almost like a response
you can hold a contest to be the white
guy because i'm sure
a bunch of your sims would enjoy doing
that oh my god
i don't love it stevie would let me have
any other like doing that
god that would be so viral huh that
would go so viral i would buy a house
the next day i would buy a house at the
very least
good for you so kinder staying at serial
killer portraits in your home i have
kids so it's frowned upon but if i was
by myself
i would probably be some charlie manson
stuff on the wall i can lie to you
yeah that culture the whole thing i
don't say big fan because he killed
people
technically but so you'd king it oh
you'd sing it
you can sing it relax
would i have charles manson's hair
framed maybe yeah
i probably i'm so into serial killers
it's alarming it's alarming see i
see i like serial killers but i can't
watch like investigation discovery
investigate
i can't watch it unless unless people
are home
like i genuinely if i even if my
five-year-old daughter is home
then i can watch it like somebody has to
be in the house if i'm by myself i can't
do it dude
but how crazy is that that you of course
can and i'm like a relatively big guy
too not like you but you could
you would you would literally rip off
ted bundy's head and [__] down his neck
but you're scared of him i'm terrible
so am i i'm legit terrified if like rich
i would beat the [__] out of richard
maybe he's wiry
ted bundy would annihilate ted bundy i'd
[__]
you kill women dude you want to hear why
dahmer would uh eat your ass
yeah okay okay dude you wanna hear a
wild ted bundy story
um uh you know comedian ryan hamilton
yeah great guy right now yeah what's he
look like he's got a netflix special
ryan hamilton he told us this story and
i i don't know if i have the characters
right but dude we were sitting on the
edge of our seats in new york i was like
ah
his i think it's his sister his sister
somebody extremely close to me either
sister is like aunt
anyway went on a date with a guy oh well
he has the biggest smile in the world
yeah his biggest smile
went on a date with a guy in utah in
like the 70s because there are mormons
in utah or something like that in the
70s ted bunny went through utah goes on
a date right
with this guy and she's on the date
and she calls her bro like in the middle
of the date they're in a public
restaurant she calls
her i think ryan or ryan's older brother
and it's like hey can you come pick me
up
this guy's just weird vibes so so
they're like yeah fine we'll come pick
you up no problem
he had picked her up from the house so
he knew the guy knew
where she lived so he the
the brother comes and picks up uh the
sister is his sister
go and she's like i just was freaked out
by that day blah blah the brother leaves
at like six o'clock in the morning
because he had like a paper route
and he was like rustling in the bushes
and sees the guy's car from the night
before
and she says and so he was hiding there
all night like waiting for her to come
out
fast forward dedication yeah dude this
is like before anything it was [__]
ted bundy she was on the daily
with ted bundy she said his name was ted
she's a handsome devil and he had
she hadn't seen and nobody had seen him
he wasn't
famous yet he had killed people already
but he wasn't on the news it wasn't
until it was two years later
when his face was everywhere she was
like that was the guy yeah dude he
almost got [__] bundied
damn yeah man almost got bundy that was
ryan hamilton's story
i think it was ryan or ryan no i he
never told it on stage he told it to
talk to his friends
no he told you i was talking inside a
comedy club dude and then
i just had on my podcast uh the chrissy
chaos podcast
i just had my uh i just had my uh
girlfriend's uncle
who's transgendered who just got out of
prison his name's tt jerry
so uh oh i saw those cliffs yeah jenny
from the cell block
nick jenny from the cell phone jenny
from the blog so tt jerry here we go
fresh out of prison with tt
so tt first of all tt jerry he came into
my apartment on the apartment yeah he
came he came into my apartment wearing
one of my sweatshirts and i gave him
like two months ago from the denver
comedy works
and then left wearing my girlfriend's
sweatshirt so he just goes guy or girl
like
in the same day he just transforms
whatever he wants to do but he was a
woman for for the interview with me he
was tt and he told us
he was in prison for 25 years like on
and off like
he did like 15-year sentence and came
out then did five did he go away for
drugs
yeah drugs and larceny steal all that
stuff yeah yeah
all that yeah whatever it was but he's
just tt cj's so he would tell us
he told us that he was in prison when he
was in first time he was in prison he
was in prison with tupac
so he was like you know and and we were
googling like what prison was it what
tell us and he wasn't lying and it was
was not lying well
who else so tupac and he said tupac was
actually like fun
in in prison but he was he said he he
got out of prison like a month or so
before he died
but he was like he was like wanted to
like give up like he was
still rapping but he wanted to give up
like life of crime and then he got
killed
so he was like so that was sad but but
he was in prison with the son of sam
and a guy who just died a couple of
weeks ago
ronald defeo jr who did the amityville
horror house
like like the actual dad he now he was
like actual cell mates with him or
shared a wall was he crazy or no he said
he said son of sam
not crazy son of sam has like or didn't
appear crazy where he was like
he was nuts back you've seen son of sam
bring him up nick dude he said
yeah uh he said his um dog was telling
him to do all these crazy things
um but he kind of reap he's all about
david looking guy
he's all about religion now though he's
like one full catholic yeah they always
do
they always do yeah because they're
trying to save their asses to get to
heaven so he's a jewish kid but he just
won full
he went full catholic and and but he
said ronald defeo jr the amityville
horror house guy
he would sit in his cell every day like
did not miss a day
just being like i didn't kill my grandma
the last one i had to kill was my
grandma i had to kill my grandma he
would always talk about killing his
grandma and tt jerry said
you know he was a pretty horny guy
ronald defeo junior so because tt was
trans and he had like ads in plants and
had actually he was on
there i mean like did he see it dude he
would take his mirror and let and let
defeo junior jerk off to his ass picks
which is nice yeah yeah
or not but he won't suck him off he
claims he didn't but we kind of all feel
he did yeah
yeah we kind of paid to go there but
you're locked in a cell that was a wild
effort
like dick dude it was a fan to talk to
someone who's been in prison for 25
years and how they see the world
and someone who's transgendered who's
been transgendered since like they were
he was like i knew i was in the wrong
body when i was like eight he's like
so he was like i was trans he had these
interesting points he was like i was
trans before it was cool he was like
all of a sudden now everybody's trans
he's like which
maybe that's true he's like or maybe
it's just
these kids are like they want to go like
goth and now but they're but they'll cut
their dick off
he's like you know if you cut it off
like it's not coming back he's like so i
just hope that the kids that do this
like really want to do this yeah he's
like i will i've all i've ever wanted in
my life was a [__] and we were like
dude we're gonna get it for you
and his estrogen therapy stopped because
when he got out of prison so we were
all the proceeds of like you know my his
patreon episode patreon.com
christy comedy um my the merch that we
made for him all that stuff is going to
his estrogen therapy so he can continue
to have the abs and tits he's got little
titties and his ass
he's just you know listen puerto ricans
they all everybody in my girl's family's
got a fat ass
everybody yeah yeah everybody's got a
nice ass
so but yeah dude serial killers man so
i'm going to king it and i'm going to
have a picture of
a son of sam in my house so td jerry can
jerk off to it oh
i'm a family guy yeah
is this quagmire what's this guy want oh
[__]
[Laughter]
what's up guys this is brandon from
minneapolis brandon
i have a king at or staying up for you
guys this week so i don't know if you
had any like super dope like
birthday themes or anything where you're
growing up as a kid
but i saw this video on the internet the
other day and i want to know if we king
it or sting it
this kid's birthday party and entrance
gang gang party party baby yeah
what's a wwe entrance oh my god
oh that's so cool he's dead serious like
stone cold
yeah what's the greatest party of all
time
awesome just take two beers and look at
that
yeah oh it takes two waters at least
he's dead serious there it is
[Applause]
he's the knee braces on i'm all for it
dude i remember when i was like eight my
mom tried going all out and she got me
this custom cake because my favorite
players were steve atwater for the
denver broncos my
home team and junior seau and my mom got
a special
custom cake where steve atwater was
tackling junior sale
and she thought i'd be like oh this is
crazy because of my two favorite players
but they were both on defense and i was
so upset
do you ever think you can i cried do you
ever think you could put a shotgun to
your chest
what do you mean that's what junior ceo
did when he killed himself oh put a
shotgun to it because you want to
preserve his brain
how wild is that oh you must have to
[__]
really have a headache
he's my favorite person of all time
you want to talk about a good looking
guy oh the best dude and he was young
with that mustache
junior only fans i'd be on it oh me too
yeah yeah hell yeah he's like playing
with his bottle
but um shout out to junior sale but uh
how long ago was that
uh a few years ago have you ever watched
the dock no i haven't
it's sad it's it's of course extremely
sad but it's like yeah dude he shot
himself in the chest
is so [__] up he tried killing himself
and driving
off pch and you know it doesn't work
like that he just like went down the
hill
yeah what the [__] he's like oh i fell
asleep they're like dude you're a junior
sail like you
your body's been through more [__]
though yeah yeah yeah this isn't gonna
do it man
yeah but what's weird is he shot himself
with a shotgun
and then if you look at the kurt cobain
one okay i'm not conspiracy gabby ever
looked into that
goddess corny love killed him maybe for
sure for sure even even
even his daughter thinks she killed him
right and that's her daughter
yeah yeah i i don't cause you look at
the shark and he did it with they're
like
there's no there's literally and then
where the shell rode
rolled they're like there's no way
there's no way i could do it yeah yeah
and the amount of uh heroin that was in
his body
they said he would have passed out by
injecting that much heroin he would have
passed out before pulling dude what if
you get cte
are you gonna shoot i think i do now and
it made me funnier so
it made you funnier but what are you
gonna do if you get to a junior sale
will you preserve your brain or what do
you want how do you want us to kill you
oh man
what do you want us to do i probably
have tt do it you want to do it you
should just
he'll just milk you until you [__]
milk me driving
i hope yeah that would suck if you
[__] did that but what are you going
to do if you did it i
[Music]
no i love you dude look at this fat [__]
no i'm kidding he's handsome he's a good
person this is luke and i'm coming at
you from detroit michigan
i'm in the workshop today and i got a
king interesting for you guys
so i have been working on a little
prototype to get rid of the um
that old wet wiper those fancy bidets
everybody wants you know
it's just an advertising thing those
things don't really clean you out the
way that they do they're supposed to
if you do it right i've got you guys
still here there's a little invention
i've been working on
i'm calling it the shitbuster 4000.
oh wow that won't be that big this is
just a prototype it's not gonna
dude it's the size dude is that active
[__] on it dude it's the size of an
f-150
who the [__] gonna put that in there
he mentions who
who might use this one and uh i'll power
it up for you and show you how it works
it's probably pretty obvious but you
know you'll just get that thing in there
it's cleaned out real good you feel like
your boy that one's a little big it's a
custom size that we had made for tim
dillon
into our company so uh what do you guys
think
i love this i like it dude [__] buster 4
000.
i'm king i just can't i can't king this
kid i'm king it the shipbuster 4000 is a
hit no i'd like to invest
i'm gonna king on the shipbuster 4000
for sure this kid now
could you get it a tad smaller though
for me i know it's a prototype but now
let me ask you though is that a used
shipbuster no i think i think that's
like those chinchilla you know fur
because it looks like a sh active [__]
on it
it looks like his boys were kind of
trying to yeah looks like yeah like [__]
on like a paper straw
also does everyone need like an
individual [__] buster oh yeah
i guess like you need your own toilet
for that yeah every time you go to
you got to grab that [__] he's hating on
bidets have you used a
new one like the electronic ones where
you press the buttons yeah because
that's living dad that's mine buy this
one
you want a bidet a nice one yeah okay
does it do warm water or cold water uh
it's like it's not like
cold but i mean it's gonna be cold
because it's just like oh [__] you have
one at your crib
yeah and then does it also blow too the
there's one that i just blow dry your
ass too oh
you don't have the big boy you don't
have that tushy 4 000. there's a tushy
fourth out there they got a big one they
have one that they have one that's like
all different temperatures of water
and yeah [__] music yes
you don't have a tushy no no they don't
sponsor they feel like they sponsor
everybody's podcast
not mine man not mine you guys got
something better
tell you what it's your boy's birthday
it's theo's birthday
spicy bros or pisces bros or you call
spicy bros whatever you want man
if you're gonna get us something make
sure it is a diamond
from blue nile surprise theo you're
getting a diamond studded earring
all right uh whatever you want man they
have high
quality jewelry are you looking for a
gift that sparkles this holiday
maybe saint patty's day instead of
getting your girl green bear you get her
a blue
nile diamond go to bluenile.com all
right
it's time to mark a special occasion got
you covered blue
nile you can create uh build the
engagement ring of her dreams never
settle at blue now.com
choose from more than 100 000 ethically
sourced
gi a graded diamonds in every shape and
size with
endless selections of settings to help
you design the ring aaron's pendant of
her dreams
we got you guys covered all right you
can also pick from a vast selection of
preset diamond
and gemstone jewelry blue now offers
endless options
ready to ship the same day also if you
get your girl or your mans
i don't like men's anymore if you get
them something that they don't like no
problem
man 100 satisfaction guaranteed shop
stress free
with guaranteed free shipping and
returns
make your moments sparkle with jewelry
from bluenow.com
and king of the sting listeners get 50
off 500. this is a podcast exclusive
offer includes engagement use code k-ats
that's code k-a-t-s plus every order is
insured ships free
and arrives in the street low package so
it doesn't give away the surprise
shop stress free and find your forever
piece go to bluenow.com today all right
go to bluenow.com today promo code
k-a-t-s
today's episode of king in the sting
with chrissy dumbells is brought to you
by the kratom experts at super specio
that's right you guys know if you
followed me for any amount of time i'm
always loaded up
jacked up on kratom and you always ask
me my dms or in the comments what kratom
do you use
this is what i use that's why they're
sponsoring out super speciosa
is the only kratom i trust it's the wild
west
kratom out there and you got to be able
to trust one that's why superspeciosa
is unlike any other kratom out there
they keep their kratom the way nature
intended all right it's pure
you don't have to stress you're getting
the right stuff exactly what you need
if you're going to try kratom has to be
from superspeciosa all right
i got you trusted man these other browns
they're full of [__] not super speciosa
plus they're giving you guys 20
off so if you want to try it get 20
percent off kratom's the [__] go to
get super leaf dot com slash kats that's
get
super leaf l e a f dot com slash k
a t enter the promo code cats for 20 off
that's
getsuperleaf.com kats promo code k-a-t-s
what else you got nick
oh hi
would you rather lose all your money or
all your [__] memories bro like
can get her sing it and then she's got a
quick follow-up okay so that was
actually not king or singer's debate
club and i'm high
[Laughter]
she's hot as [__] what that body do baby
so king in the sting
what what was it king or something or
sting it uh memories or losing your
memories
uh losing your money or your memories
yeah my money
because we lose all your memories i
don't know where the [__] yeah who
cares
yeah who gives a [__] i could be dana
white with 400 million dollars i don't
know what the [__]
yeah i've had terrifying memories
i'll lose every single memory yeah i
feel like that one is uh i wouldn't
expect
you know her to i thought she was gonna
have a better one but
she's bodied ah those are no but she
those are real her real breasts
yes and that's her real face real face
absolutely she's from uh what is she
hawaiian
uh she looks a little japanese what are
the chances let me ask you this what are
the chances
if she continued this video and then got
up there would be a nice set of [__] and
balls
what are the chances of that that would
top it the [__] yeah and then
we got tt'ed yeah
we didn't king or sting the kid's uh
birthday party we didn't
we oh i just i just shared a sad story
at my birthday party
oh yeah i king that kid's birthday okay
because my birthday is not giving i'm
on my birthday my party i'll be getting
off a
southwest flight in spokane that'll be
fun though
yeah it'd be great i would i don't know
what i would do
maybe i'd sting it i think i'm gonna
sting this kid's party
there were no master social distances
[Laughter]
do you go nuts for your kids b-day party
for my kid's birthday yeah for my kid's
birthday last year
we had i didn't tell her mom i you know
i at that at that point we weren't
together we were together now right
together now she's pregnant we're
july 4th my child's due oh july 4.
boy or girl do you know we don't know
yet but boy
yeah it feels like it's a boy and we're
going to name it donald um
imagine we did he'd be the only one
could you imagine what do you think's
actually a bigger problem
like if i name my kid donald or adolf
what do you think would be a bigger
issue donald do you think donald would
be a bigger issue like
because adolf that people it's so old
school
would get it yeah the jews in new york
would be really upset but
general yeah the world like adolf that's
different that's the yeah it's k
yeah don yeah i um yes sir donald's a
problem
july 4th dude that's when the the babies
do so she got pregnant and then you were
like yeah she's probably trying to make
this work
well no week we were back to get got
back together in quarantine
and then we had kept saying like we're
gonna take things slow this time because
the last time
when you know i on the second or third
date she got
pregnant with our daughter and then
we're like oh like we got back together
during quarantine like let's try to make
this work we'll take it very
very slow you know and then literally
probably the fourth time
we had sex just pregnant again just
immediately again
chrissy dumbbell swimmers what it is
dude and then she's puerto rican
yeah dangerous combo it just it's just
whatever it is with us
where it's just like it's just constant
like it's just constant humans
we just constantly make people that's
what it is and then i got friends of
mine
who bought you know both fertile myrtles
but they just can't
they just can't do it they just it's
like a science where it's like
if you're a fertile and she's fertile
that doesn't mean you guys are gonna
have kids
like this it has to like your sperm has
to like her egg yeah my sperms see those
puerto rican huevos and like
[Laughter]
yeah uh should we move on some
relationship advice
yeah i like this full set of lips
look at that nice chain what's up
brendan vaughn what's up theo shop
how's it hanging nick and chin and how's
it going to whatever guests you guys got
in the studio this week because you guys
fired cat and chappelle
from honolulu hawaii and i need some
relationship advice from you guys
my girlfriend's been wanting to wax my
[__]
and i just don't know how to feel about
it well you don't look hair hand
it'll probably make her a little happier
you know every man gives me a little
extra
points really on the other hand every
man is not looking down there you know i
don't know
check how it looks every day i don't
care how hairy it gets that thing can
grow wild for all i care
but what do you guys think when your
girlfriend walks around hanging it doggy
do it here's the thing though i had my i
my girl wanted to do it to me too and i
was like sure why not
and i said but let's try it just on my
inner thigh see how bad it hurts dude
hurts right girls go through it all the
time dude
i want you are not touching my [__]
yeah
to shave their [__] i mean
i guess i would let her do it i mean
it's bonding you know what i mean you're
fine
shaving is different from waxing your
[__] though he said waxing so waxing
is like
piping hot wax on your ass it doesn't
even have to be piping hot they have
cool
waxes now the only problem is when you
pull it you're pulling even the hair
follicle it hurts but here's the thing
with me
is i have a skin tag on my [__] so
and i've been trying to get it off so i
feel like that might work
i would use the guys of hey can you wax
my [__] this would be fun buying
anything but really i want to get the
ward off my ass
oh that might do it then yes you might
have to say yes you gotta you gotta work
yeah
no i think it's a skin tag the doctor
says it's a skin tag
it [__] hurts but it's also not that
bonding because you either got you know
if your girl's gonna do it you gotta
decide baby style where you're holding
your ankles
well you're all on these legs she's
grabbing the balls and like going like
this where it's super
weird uncomfortable or yeah yeah on all
fours like a you know
cow and spread that how would you do it
i'd probably go baby stop put that
nut in her face
i would i think i would go i would go
all fours because i think if i went baby
style
one thousand percent i'd fart and then
if i fall
because every time i do that like even
if i haven't eaten in three days like if
i do
as soon as i go into that position i
just fart just immediately just
almost like a crunch dude and it's like
yeah i'll i'll queef like it'll just
yeah the app you're just holding it
there for that air comes out of my ass
so i would go on all fours but i think
this kid should one thousand percent let
his girl do it
i think he shouldn't report back but
also asian
like you're not that hairy if you want
your girl to eat your ass that's it
the pain is so it's so painful
especially for a man
because you have more hair there there's
more to rip off right it's gonna hurt
like a [__] if you don't want to
do it already
do you like your acid i've never gotten
my ass in i've never had any sex
i don't do there's something about you
have you licked that
oh no i've never licked an ass i just no
he's just embarrassed about the skin tag
he didn't want people to see it that's a
good point
i think i've had the skincare cd eats
ass
not that i'm against it i just because i
get a lot of sore throats not since the
panty waiting
no you wear a mask and wash your hands
but i would always get sore throats like
if i
made out with like a couple of girls or
if i like ever like went down on a girl
i would get a sore throat immediately
so i was taking the ass i mean i would
get full cancer
you get pink guys yeah that's kind of a
rumor too that you get pink eye yeah
what you're saying you don't no no right
but you do the only way to get pink eyes
fecal particles in the eye right i don't
think so
didn't kirk douglas get uh throat cancer
but that's from hpv
because you eat out girls with hpv or
suck
penis with hpv i don't know what kurt
russell's into uh no not kurt russell
douglas
kirk yeah kurt let's just start the room
at kurt russell
yeah i but i think i think um
yeah i've never done it dude i i've
never i've never even tried anal sex
that's so disappointing would you uh let
your girl wax your [__] oh yeah
go for it oh wow nice good for you who
cares do you think you have a hairy
[__]
i probably do you know like he's a bear
dog you know that's bad
beard yeah i don't bro i can't grow
anything either dude
look at it i'll tell you he's been doing
work overtime if they wax their [__]
oh my god dude
you got a duck tail down there it's like
the elastic jungle from guts
just bungee cords all over i think cat
hit it on the head though like this is
just a gateway request she's doing it to
get it clean and then the next is can i
she wants to eat your
what does it feel like when a girl eats
your ass it feels good you're looking
ready look at you
know you better answer that
it feels good huh try it out with your
girl man
yeah put your kids no you can't put your
put your kid to bed early take a shower
get on all fours and just let her eat
the ass
it's interesting i've never even thought
about it dude it's a nightmare
there's not enough wet wipes to clean my
ass yeah
i know maybe you need that bidet i do
that's what i would do
would you be down for a cat if stevie
was like i really like my assy now
uh if stevie asked i asked i'd be open
to it i've had other guys have dated in
the past asked for it
and i always said no because i just yeah
i don't trust their
them or their hygiene yes right i don't
respectfully stevie has ocd
though so you know he's clean i know
he's clean but there's something about
like
maybe it's just me i always felt like
white people never really cleaned their
ass properly
i agree with that yes i don't that's
racist yeah
i agree that is racist that's right
stevie is the cleanest man i've ever he
has ocd
yes absolutely he might be thick harry
down there because he has that sick
he doesn't want you anywhere near his
butt but here's what's that prison yeah
how long did he do seven years seven or
eight years fed eight years in federal
prison
yeah that's significant that's a
life-changing amount of time oh yeah
think about how long
eight years ago right in boston what did
he do what was the crime
i think drugs drug trafficking money
laundering conspiracy uh
selling drugs and they gave eight years
like that yeah because he was young he
was like 20 21
and they gave him eight years yeah he
took a deal
wow so we could have got way more yeah
he could have gone more have you ever
met steven
no was he a comedian yeah yeah no i
never met him huge cop
really big he also used to before he
used to do porn where can i see his work
uh i'll have him send me a pic point hub
probably online what's his uh what's his
name
you know uh nicole anderson uh i know
jennifer aniston
nope nope who's nicole aniston porn's
the biggest foreigner
look at this dude chrissy dumbbells you
don't know do your acid
or water jerk off to women's tennis
okay so you've never seen her yeah that
was this girl before cat
okay upgrade oh thanks
i think nicole's beautiful though super
dynamic stunning
so i've seen in person and do they still
now if if nicole aniston
and stevie blois were to do a pointing
together you're okay with that um
not anymore no uh initially he and i
first started dating i
was i didn't really want to spend extra
time with him because of that i was like
oh like we'll hang out hook up whatever
but i don't want anything more to do
with you
then he quit porn because he knew i
wouldn't want anything to do with him
because of that
he quit porn because that and then also
i can't have you on the road with me
i can't
yeah i get it we got a business to run
here it's interesting though because
porn stars because he's just going to
work like that's what it would be he
just goes to work and yeah
he'll be okay puts
[Music]
i'd like to see his [__] can we pull his
[__] up yeah he hides
we can't see uh hey she knows where to
get it yeah she's a big
can we just get stevie blue eyes penis
she wants to see it
his hammer too yeah i'm like he pulls it
out it's like this cake iguana tail dog
really just [__] that's hot as we're
waiting for it you want to do another
yeah please this guy was definitely
talking in this thing
to julian uh apparently late at night
with the yosemite sand mustache
i got a relationship advice question it
does not have to do with that cat
um it's more like a single as a pringle
question
you know we've got a coffee business and
we're growing it really quickly
currently we're working with some
comedians and musicians i just hit up
chappelle
for instance to do something but you did
i'm curious if you think that
waiting to date until you've reached a
certain point of success
not just like stability but like success
is a bad thing
yes uh if i should be dating while
succeeding or if i should wait until i
think that i've quote unquote made it
um is that bad to wait
you know should i stay in the game or
should i not
should i not stay in the game or should
i just make that bread and eat it
uh like my role model brenden shop
eating the bread and making the bread
yes um
anyways gang gang boats buzz let me know
buzz buzzer man good luck with your
coffee oh
yeah dude you don't want a gold digger
you don't get all rich and you don't
know
what they're most ride or die my girl
used to sleep on the floor with me in a
uh square foot apartment that's really
sing
see i think people like this though like
this guy i think
when you start to think about it all
like that like when i was getting from
him was like
you know you you have to just like go
like just be in the moment like just
live like you're like should i wait for
this should i wait to have kids should i
it's like no dude life will just go yeah
just go yeah just make the coffee make
the bread eat the bread get a girlfriend
like it'd all be fine
it's like we're never the right time was
bread the reference to money
i guess he's talking i don't know a kid
like this i don't know
yeah just go i'm with you just go like
if you meet a great girl
yeah dude why not no people like oh i'm
waiting to have success to have kids
like no
then you're never gonna get hair mike
doesn't care just shut up and make it
work
i'm having a second child
do you feel stressed about it it's
different with two no you know what i
feel
less stressed because i feel like you
know yeah and i feel like you know i'm
excited about it like eve
i literally people something like my
family will like look at my life
sometimes but i don't know how you deal
with what you deal with i don't know
like what a nightmare i'm like no dude i
just love being a dad yeah
so like just getting to be with my kid
every day i love and then
having a second child i'm like double
that down i'm like what's the
what's the problem yeah i tell my girl
like all the love these kids
give why not keep going man yeah dude
i'm just getting a squad yeah
i want like four you want four kids four
would you adopt
probably not you would just not you know
i would consider it
right yeah now what are you what is sean
cash what's your name
is german and what's what's the other
part has to be uh
has to be border uh
you're over the wall you're half over
the wall you have to be half over the
wall
are you not half over the wall i'm not
even close what are you mongolian or
something
like you too so your parents are telling
you the truth yeah maybe you guys are
adopted
oh that's that'd make more sense that's
going to be what it dude there's no way
you're not a little mexican but you look
like your dad you look like your dad
yeah
and he's not mexican more mongolian dude
it's so
bizarre it's that dark italian dark
italian yeah
yeah but brendan schaab shall
shop jobs german is fun shot yes
yeah you're one of those guys who yeah
if you were born in like the 1920s
and you would be a not you'd be a
first-round draft pick from mr hitler
he would say come play with us
you are a big guy and you're a hitler mr
hitler would say yes
they dye your hair blonde they give you
blue eyes crystal meth a little they
call it ponzer chocolate that's right i
would say you
will march in the snow yeah and you
would have to go kill those polish
people
dude you'd be a nightmare dude i'll do
it
imagine me like with my [__] us
uniform on and then you
this [__] crazy just mma nazi running
on me
on meth just with [__] skinny jeans
on just [__] tickling balls i don't
know what's happening
just eating everybody's ass on the
battlefield
uh stevie also says it's okay for me to
show you a dick pic yeah oh great
air drop that to me oh but
show us the non but i want to see it
like for me yeah
for you what's the information yeah dude
i'm either going to jerk off to his pick
or eat this cake so
private archive your private you want a
picture of your friend's dick in your
arms
whoa wow
[__] yeah that was the perfect thing
dude that's the perfect home tattoo too
just looking up at that clock homer
simpson
that's exactly my face that's cat's face
every night
what a beautiful [__] too what a
beautiful mushroom head
has my favorite dick look how thick that
thing is this thing is [__]
i look perfectly shaved hairless i don't
know why isn't the homework tattoo but
whatever
dude is not his dude it's nuts and
they're
look at how smooth it is it looks like a
sphynx cat what do you think that a
about eight nine inches i would say
eight i would say a solid i say
like eight and a half yeah but does it
hurt uh
at first yes but then you get used to it
yeah yeah
no dude look at that i mean in great
shape too is he a tall boy too is he
told you're in the water
he's a short baby boy a little tiny foot
dude look a little tiny baby feet
he's big wear matters yeah he's bigger
matters there you go okay he's in crazy
shape
oh i'll be dude you could tell yeah all
right my body has not looked like that
handsome kid
oh dude i'm the ugliest one of the crew
but yeah but you're you're a cutie i'm
all right
i'm not gonna swing the crew
stevie stevie looks good chappelle man
my brother but have you seen alex malik
smelly i know it's an outlook in person
i remember malik in person looks like uh
jason derulo
like ally cavern nice so okay yeah he's
yeah okay
i'm the ugly one look at that arms the
beard yeah he's just
how old is he now uh 34. 34 still a
young kid
yeah there you go oh here we go this is
this this
looks latina so i'm going to just stay
quiet
because if i even look at another one
she's a woman she's so pretty there's a
problem
what is up guys my name is silver i'm
from san jose california la living
shout out to you cat i know you'd be
repping shade too
so here's my dilemma
um a year ago i was definitely ghosted
by a 36 year old man
grown-ass man right i'm 29.
um ghosting should be long gone we're
grown um
but given no explanation because i was
definitely blocked the whole nine yards
so i took that to heart figured i was
the issue got on my grind started
working out
eating right all that stuff so
a whole year later dude wants to come
back now do i let him back in
part of me is kind of like oh part of me
is like [__] you
you [__] me up so um
should i let it ride
should i say [__] you
help a girl out i need to i need more
details on him yeah does he have that
stevie blue eyes dick
if he does then i'm going to say yes
write it out i'd like to say
i am i would be willing to bet yet
another thousand dollars that
as sure as i was that that asian girl
with the fakes
would get up and have a dick and balls
if silver
her name's silver latina girl named
silver
guarantee you everybody knew that
guarantee you guarantee you if she
unbuttoned her shirt or took her shirt
off
100 tattoo on the tent yeah 100
it's a guaranteed slam dunk tattoo on
the tip tattoo on the tit one thousand
print maybe a robe
[Music]
miguel across the top tit and she
probably is leaving out you're right
she's leaving out like a lot of info
like i didn't just ghost you either as a
wife and family or you [__] blew his
house up you lit his car on fire
you did something crazy i blacked out
and then you went home and made
empanadas and you forgot that you
[__] beheaded his wife yeah she's
talking all soft and [__]
yeah i got ghosts she didn't
just get ghosted though she got blocked
she might have killed his cat
yeah she did something she did something
she's like she looks like a baddie
though because she's gorgeous
gorgeous girl but this is dangerous
beautiful and crazy latina that's
latinas in a nutshell
that's latinos in a nutshell yeah spicy
yeah my daughter i worry about my
daughter man my daughter's just
a little little latina my daughter's and
now as my daughter's getting older i'm
like
[__] she looks exactly like her mom like
it's gonna be a problematic thing my
father was saying from my daughter's boy
he's like you better hope she looks like
you
you better hope that little girl looks
like you because she looks like the
kid's mother you can have a problem
yeah i know and she's every day i'm like
just send my dad pictures everybody's
like wow that looks like your [__]
girlfriend
he's like i can't help you i can't help
you i'm gonna be dead soon i'm like yeah
dude i know it's gonna be a problem so i
kind of hope
i'm ve that's why people like oh what do
you want a boy or a girl i'm like i
really would like
of course just a healthy baby but i
don't know if i could deal deal with two
girls
that are like minnie me's my girlfriend
two smoke show a little bit
yeah it's gonna be an issue it's just
gonna be an issue but what am i gonna do
are your daughters how old five my
daughter's five my son's five wow
they should hang out yeah imagine they
get together they're both
half latina half white oh that's wrong
should we hang look what you guys just
did
wow that's true when are the birthdays
my daughter's birthday is may 19th
february 21st so
so your your boy just turned five just
turned five yeah mine's
yeah mine's turned six in a couple of
months okay we should
well yes you can bring them up by the
crib absolutely all out here
everybody's out here dude i came with
the puerto ricans this sounds like an
arranged
marriage yeah it sounds like some [__]
my parents would have done it's gonna be
great is she
active though because my son won't stop
is my daughter active yeah dude she was
up today at five o'clock in the morning
because we're still on new york times
she put the nutribullet on by herself
with nothing on top
yeah we were like we woke up and we were
like it was like she was like i have the
nutribullet going i'm like you literally
don't have anything on top of it she's
like well put something on it
this is fun little play date we got all
my daughter's nuts
this guy's got a debate club now no cat
let me ask you quickly
how much how much money to eat his ass
to eat his house yes is love included or
not
no no no no this isn't this is strictly
financial
no he's on account
and he's like yo cat name your price to
eat this
ac dc ass um
is this being recorded for something or
is it just an experience
studio you walk in he's on all fours
your only fan's page we took it away
you're not getting that incoming where
you have
zero income so that you have you have to
this is fight or flight what are you
going to do how much
you tomorrow that's what you're saying
rent's due tomorrow due tomorrow yeah
absolutely stevie blue is left he's
[__] out of here blue eyes yeah okay
he's back in prison
with the uh circumstance that you are
like all
shower clean and prepped i will give you
that four
i wasn't even thinking 10 if like rent
is due i'm like
i come from like refugee mentality of
like a job is a job just do
it well yeah i was gonna say like
five grand five grand [__]
if i really needed the money if i really
needed the money that's a good five
thousand thousand that's like i couldn't
i would have given you anything i have a
blank check here
five million i would have said sure you
go five grand
see this is why we have to go to war in
vietnam
we'll win again and we will win five
grand
wow five grand see if like rent is due
tomorrow and i absolutely needed to pay
it then yes five grand but if you're
saying
like realistically i'm talking about
you're living in modern day los angeles
not in the rice paddies in vietnam
will that even stop
and i said per i could have said no
shower right after a [__]
and you would be like six grand
how much would you to eat his ass right
now
am i horny or not horny uh yeah you're
turned on i'm turned on medium just saw
stevie's big dick
clean ass yeah he's like and i've never
eaten an asterisk so this would be my
first ass heat
i would do this guy's ass i would say i
do this guy's ass
before i do it for i do it for a million
dollars because i put half in uh bitcoin
so i know i make my money yeah i go
right into crypto i put 500k in crypto
bank
oh that's a good point buy me a bitcoin
i'll eat your ass so
so well bitcoin right now is 58 000 so
you're a little short
yeah so yeah um
uh before you start talking [__] about
me
no we're just talking about how much
you're gonna eat your ass man
it's a low price he should be yeah seems
like a gentle
jim brewer [__] syndrome to where i
look like i'm [__] baked but i
actually haven't smoked
in almost three weeks now i just this is
how i naturally [__] look
um it's your boy adam dirty out in wash
state
oh my god i'm making the girls shake
remember that his name is adam dirks oh
mostly they just shake their head
no but whatever i got a debate club for
you guys
would you rather have a night out with
your boys
or have a night in with your girl i know
that's
that's a hard thing to decide sometimes
so i'm gonna see what my girl thinks
about that babe
babe what do what do you think about
that no way he has a girlfriend yeah he
does
yeah i think you should stay in with me
definitely don't listen that [__] she
doesn't know what she's talking about
so or staying inside
love you guys uh shout out to culture
corner
uh chappelle if you ever want to do some
karaoke you know go out and sing a
little bit of matchbox 20 get down on
that
hit me up he's got hitting on me
yeah i'll leave you guys eat his ass
for two mills wow i wish i saw that
before i answered
five thousand two yeah bring him in
[Laughter]
theo
[Music]
i'm a homebody man so unless i'm working
i'd prefer to be at home with my girl
i wouldn't say at home at night yes i'm
making money working i ain't leaving the
house i'm the same i'd rather i'm at a
point in my life where i'd would
genuinely rather just stay home i'd
rather that's that dad life
because i don't want to be hungover i
want to wake up with my son at 5 00 a.m
dude even now what time it's 3 36 it's
like my days like i've been up so
my daughter woke up at 5 15 and it's
like two i i can't like i'm done by six
o'clock seven o'clock i'm done
i'm in bed at nine yeah andrew santino
was like let's do the pot
he wants to do uh whiskey ginger tonight
he's like let's do it tonight at ten
o'clock i'm like
ten o'clock andrew absolutely no dude
there's
i can't even pro i can't even attempt
i'm not even remotely funny or creative
after maybe 5 p.m i can't i'm spent dude
i got to do it in the morning yeah it's
like i
i didn't do uh bobby lee's show what was
his name of the show your brother about
it
i i didn't do that for years he kept
asking me he's like i shoot monday
nights at 8 p.m like nah
bubba i i get kids man i shut it down
dude i want to get to a point where
ticket sales where like
i would only want to do one night or and
or if i'm gonna do two shows legit do
one at five o'clock and seven o'clock
like if i could sell sell and be like yo
come out to a five o'clock show
two and a seven o'clock show because
dude even the thought
even the thought and i'm you know lucky
and fortunate we're like where i go like
the tickets are sold and everything is
sold out it's beautiful
but i'm just like sometimes like that 9
45 show i'm like i can't do this like
i'm
so tired just the thought of being on
stage
because it starts 15 minutes late and
then the open is going to go on by 10
30.
i can't dude i'm like i don't i as soon
as i get on i want to get off and i'm
like now i'm not giving a good
pr performance for the people that paid
and i you know just try to muscle
through it but i'm like i want to get to
a point where i do five and seven
that's like legitimately my girl i think
she was asking me goals and stuff
because my birthday's coming up
i said i want to get to a certain level
where i'm big enough where i either do
just one show a night
yeah or two shows and one night and come
back home yeah oh yeah no
on thursday friday saturday i take less
money i take
i take less money to do one show yeah
but the goal is either like
rogan or chappelle burr like the big boy
segura
where they fly in one night they get
their pay and sell a [__] ton of tickets
and fly back home
yeah that's that those are [__] you
goals yeah but now but now with
remember they used to grind like us yeah
no i i know we still have to do what we
have to do but i mean
i've been doing now i've been headlining
for six years i mean like
35 weekends a year 40 weekends a year
sometimes so it's like
i feel like i've done it now i've i've
been every club i've done [__] eight
you know
the wednesday to sundays a thousand
shows for a thousand dollars whatever it
is
i feel like now i want to just like i
don't even care there's
i have no desire to be like a level
famous like looking at this so you get
canceled i don't want to do that
i got a buddy you guys would all know he
got offered a big movie he's like nope
and i was like you had your [__] mind
dude he's like
i don't want to get that famous man he's
like the [__] i've said on podcasts and
stand up like i'll get cancelled
yeah dude he's like it's not worth it
yeah again for what who
gives a [__] movies and it's all about
having like a niche audience dude if you
can have like
10 000 die hard fans there's billions of
people on this planet if you just have
ten thousand
true die hard fans you'll have a career
yeah you literally can have a career
with just
your life so my i'm done trying to chase
like i want everybody to love me
i don't care anymore it's like yeah i
want the fans who like me
to continue and keep them and hold them
and and serve them but other than that
yeah
i'm like dude i don't know even doing
this true tv show like
you know i'm just like i'm doing it
specifically because i'm out in la
so i can do podcasts and if they find
something i send a podcast i want to
cancel me i'd be like that's fine too
yeah then i'll just go back to my fans
and i feel safe
because of the podcasting i'm like you
can't take you really
what are you going to take from me
canceling me is what taking away my
money okay that
fine you take away the money on tv fine
it's still there in the podcasting
you know i still have a patreon podcast
also how you sell tickets on the road
because the people who get cancelled for
like real [__] it's like that's one
thing but people get cancelled for words
your fans are actually never going to
leave you you shane gillis has probably
got more fans from what he went through
if he was on his own he would have just
came and went dude you know what the
difference is shane gillis he he has
talent he's a beast but i'm saying if
you have talent and all you did was
say a joke that crossed the line a
little bit but even though we're
comedians and that's what we're supposed
to
i feel like that's our role in society
your fans i doubt are going to work
people people show up for shane yeah bro
as they should man
but but it's also like you know with
people we know who
supposedly been canceled the public
decides if you're canceled they'll give
you a career if
they they'll look at all the evidence
and they decide they don't want
hollywood
no clubs i'd rather have my appetizers i
want my career in the hands of the
public i don't want my career in the
hands of [__] colgate toothpaste no
[__] you shout out rebrand santa
guys this is jake from buffalo new york
i got a debate quote for you hot in here
nick
podcast merch who's got the best
right here i got that cancel clothing on
my frills
oh here i got the thick boy slash
fire and the kid along with old rolly
boy
and lacey up there h3 podcast with their
brand teddy fresh and last but not least
that gang gang rat king hitter from this
past weekend
what do you guys think who has it gang
gang go bills
go bills i was on the bills for three
minutes um
as far as merch man i was asking who has
the who has the best i you know my
favorite was
chris well you know what the [__] was
going on i used to wear his [__]
the h3 they they do it right i was going
to say h3 is probably the best but
you know the rest of them isn't even
really merch it's like a clothing line
it's different yeah yeah that's that's
what stick boy is moving towards more of
a
clothing line yeah out of all that that
they've showed on the bed
i have to go with probably teddy fresh
the h3 merch out of that but
that's a that's also don't get me wrong
that's a good sick boy shirt sweatshirt
but that's also not
representative of we have some dope [__]
like have you seen the letterman jackets
no i'm so sick yeah now he's selling you
on his merch look at that
dude well the king and the sting uh
black sweatshirt is dope
yeah that colin walked in with now if we
go off sales
i don't know did h3 there they move they
move major
numbers though right but you guys move
them out you think you guys move the
most
big boy moves merch man it moves a lot
of thickies out there a lot of things
but h3 i'm not too familiar i know
they're a married couple that started
they're huge
so i'm sure they do well i bet we both
do well yeah yeah out of those yeah
yeah i would say flagrant ii moves a lot
of merch too i think schultzy sells a
lot of march
tim dillon i like tim dillon's merch
thanks for the shirt tim
um yeah shots he's inching because he'll
just take like a rip of an off-white
shirt and put his name on it i'm like
how do you get away with this yeah i
guess he's the merchant until somebody
sues you and also
schultz thanks for the merch yeah he was
like your package is in the mail i'm
like
he's like i bet someone's stolen like no
i would know dude
yeah no i i don't know i i mean but my
thing like obviously everyone does merch
i love
fashion and merch right like i'm not
guys like oh just put this logo on it
like i'm
designing and putting it yeah i love it
you love doing that i've been doing it
forever i bet you i've been doing it
longer than everyone on there
oh you had merch even before a podcast
yeah yeah
yeah dude if i'm your merch should just
be your one of your cauliflower ears
just on his shirt
just bang i would i would wear that dude
i'd like bite me
should we close out with one race my
case yes no what's this called what's
the reason why case
race might decide what race uh and this
is our
boy a listener judge justin who took our
our segment and ran with it is he an
actual judge
uh we don't know right all right all
right king of the sting crew
i'm glad you guys enjoyed my last
submission now let's get into the next
one huh
the video that landed in my lap today
was really something else and the
footage i sent over to you guys
a man can be seen walking into a public
restroom videotaping
now you may think that's pretty odd but
wait until he gets around the corner to
find a man using the urinal pretty
normal
and then a random person sniffing his
ass
the guy got a few lungfuls of that man's
buttocks
before standing up and when he stood up
he noticed he was being recorded
he uh gave the cameraman a weird look
and the walk of shame out of the
bathroom was pretty bad
what race was he boys gang gang judge
judge
let's get into it white white white
white
that gives me white votes do you wipe
white guys love to eat ass so for
christy d we got white
[Laughter]
big reveal i would say white oh there's
a world star hip-hop video of it mm-hmm
world asian
asian it has to be a japanese guy it has
to be japanese
oh he's sniffing his that's why he's
pissing
oh he caught him in the act hilariously
dude guys fart when they pee
i always yeah everything why is that i
don't know it's just
oh he caught him
that guy's a freak oh my god
dude i like how he's trying to walk out
like nothing happens oh that guy is this
is this like recently i don't know i'm
not sure i guess it's not camping
disgusting
that's oh so i thought that was a prank
that he was genuinely i know he's
probably rock hard right now oh thousand
percent dude just rocco just
wow just sniffing ass in a public urinal
2013. how do you know i feel that though
he the guy felt it dude he was turning
the guy on yeah what do you think the
guy in the urinal didn't feel it dude he
started the urine started to go up and
he was hitting himself in the chin he
was getting a bonus
hashtag stop asian hate it's just
[__] job
it's a dangerous game to play though man
because when guys are in bathroom and
everyone
no one laughs and it's just like
stopping he's farting
always ripping farms yeah well that's
what he was waiting for
yeah it is what he's waiting for that's
probably what he would have probably you
probably would have passed out he would
have came
he would have fell right on the floor oh
yeah yeah satisfaction right there
satisfaction
that's it we're gonna dive into this
cake nick let's do it let's do it
feed me i can't eat it why can't you
diet i'm gonna die too though it's my
b-day yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah that's just yeah i
can't wait for you to work out with us
tomorrow i know well if i [__]
whatever my dumb call time is
or wednesday wednesday too
probably i don't know dude it's the
first day of filming i got a pitch on
friday with comedy central
really what's it about podcast stuff
i've i've worked with comedy central a
lot i know you have
i was i was like chrissy comedy central
and then they just when the pandemic
happened and they changed ownership they
were like
bye oh yeah you hosted uh my cluster
fest
yes yeah yeah yeah i was there i was
their [__] boy
i i think i'm gonna do a 30-minute
special with them why the hell not dude
why the hell not might as well because
they'll put on tv which i don't give a
flying [__] about but they put it on
their
uh youtube on their youtube yeah oh god
that's all i want and whatever dude just
get the money up front
make sure it's right money and that's it
dude yeah because i feel like you want
to push all my fans towards that
towards that because when i do it's
showtime i was like can you please
put it on your showtime youtube like no
that's not what we do with specials
like all right
yeah let's do it is this edible on top
here
yeah yeah yeah if you want to eat ass
for the first time there's a theo's ass
on
oh oh eat that ass who made this nick
cake boss cake boss
well there's so many i gotta have a bite
is this what happens when you eat ass oh
no it's not no it's usually not
messy hold on
oh this is all sugar and frosting look i
mean theo's ass
how's it taste it's nice it's pretty
good is it good
yeah yeah
eat one more piece for me okay it is my
birthday you can't see
i'm eating your piece of cake buddy i
missed you i love you miss you love you
stop asian hate i do sound asian i do i
do
what else do asian people want i mean
they're [__] top of the class and
everything
now we can't even hate them
they [__] get everything dude i've
never met a non-successful asian
now i can't [__] get yelled once in a
while
there's a champs asian people are the
champs killing the game
all right see this is bad how many do i
put my fitness pal for this
just put is this like you think how many
this it's right
300 calories two bites three i'd say
what you ate i'd say
put in like a third of a cake slice
yeah because you didn't need a full
slice you didn't use full slice
that was good though it's it's hard to
just stop right i'm ready zoom in on his
face
it's my birthday all right one more bite
nick
gosh it looks so good you don't want any
you guys don't want anything nope i'm
good
you're not gonna you're also dieting huh
uh not dieting i just have a thing
i can't eat too much sugar diabetes runs
in my family right so you prevent it and
you don't want it you're done
i'm scared but i just have a little
piece this is my birthday what do you
think it's my favorite it's [__] good
dude what's the difference dude you lose
one foot what's the difference
it's legit one foot you can you can hop
on your stage
[Laughter]
kind of liberating oh it's nice there it
is i feel like a rebel
like you're doing something wrong yeah i
feel like a hell's angel the way we eat
this
i know dude i feel it like immediately
my heart starts to beat fast i feel like
i just got the vaccine
[Laughter]
oh it's so soft that's good daddy yeah
that's good it's a little baby piece
it's a bit it's my birthday india's
yeah damn it's not going to ruin my day
no
are you guys afraid of food now what's
happening
just put on weight i've no lost weight
no but i'm saying but did you
really
272 i'm 260 right now probably high 250.
when you were what were you before the
quarantine
260 something oh you were always a big
boy then i'm not yeah i'm a fake dude no
but but you but you hence the name thick
boy
but were you getting like a gut and
everything in like tits or like you just
don't carry it there i would carry where
do you carry it in your hips and ass
um a little bit of my tummy i was
getting a little bit of a tummy yeah
but it's gone now they you know working
on it we were eating bad on the road
we've not not recently before really
it's bad right like well you like you
wouldn't even
going to town and no and i didn't eat a
full rack of ribs we were searching for
restaurants
like the best [__] the best of the best
getting desserts and [__] everything
everything
yeah no not working yourself in the box
yeah i was just riding my bike every
[__] day i'm like how am i the
fastest i ever met i'm
averaging 30 miles a day yeah and it was
the fattest you ever was
but now i joined that zoo culture gym
and your boys getting back baby
you've earned it doug
you ready to sign off dick yeah you want
to sign out oh we're so oh
i don't know i didn't know if we were
going or not so i didn't want to say
anything oh hell yeah we're going
hell yeah christine we love you man i
appreciate it man i appreciate you guys
having me
yeah man this crew is in well not this
whole crew me and chappelle will be in
spokane this thursday friday saturday
all shows are sold out so we add a show
thursday late and saturday early
so we get tickets spokane washington and
then the next week
miami thursday friday saturday miami
improv
baby that's it we love you guys theo i
miss you love you
yeah happy birthday happy birthday theo
[Music]
i'm just popping i fell asleep in the
gucci pyjamas
double the problems
[Music]
so
you